VoVoici les chiffres du jour por
lele Québec, 323 cas, zéro décè.
HoHospitalisation, une
auaugmentation de six, il y en a
8888 actuellement. Vous allez me
didire ce n'est pas des chiffres
fafaramineux. Pourquoi le discos
sesemble vraiment très nerveux,n
totout cas, craintif du côté du
gogouvernement du Québec? On va
poposer la question à Christian
DuDubé, ministre de la Santé, qi
esest avec nous. M. Dubé voulez-
vovous annoncer la vaccination
obobligatoire pour tous les
ememployés du réseau de la sant.
C'C'est quand même un pas énormà
fafaire dans une démocratie.
QuQu'est-ce qui justifie cette
dédécision?
- - On vient souvent avec la mêe
réréponse, mais c'est vraiment a
RIRIV du variant au cours des
dedernières semaines qui nous
ffêtent craindre d'avoir une
auaugmentation très rapide et
d'd'avoir un impact sur notre
réréseau de santé. C'est pour ça
quque comme on veut protéger le
réréseau de santé, on voit les
hohospitalisation qui
mamalheureusement augmente, alos
onon veut se protéger il faut
fafaire le maximum pour ne pas
cocontinuer à faire des rapports
dede chirurgie, comme on l'a vuu
cocours des dernières, alors il
fafaut être prudent, c'est poura
ququ'on à cette mesure-là de
l'l'avant.
- - Je comprends la prudence, mé
s's'il y a 90 % du personnel dea
sasanté qui est déjà vacciné. Le
1010 % qui n'est pas vacciné, sl
rerefuse de se faire vacciner,
vovous allez les mettre de côté?
- - C'est un petit peu pour ça
ququ'on a dit : étant donné que
llà, on va sur l'intégrité des
pepersonnes, ce n'est pas une
sisimple mesure sanitaire. On va
dedemander aux gens d'être oblié
d'd'être vacciné et ce pour ça
ququ'on a demandé, on fait la
rerecommandation de celle de
l'l'santé publique, d'avoir une
opoption parlementaire pour
popouvoir discuter avec les
opoppositions, avec nos experts,
avavec les syndicats, pour être
cecertain que lorsque cette
rerecommandation va être mise en
plplace, on aura eu la chance de
didiscuter parce que c'est une
memesure très importante, la
vavaccination obligatoire dans e
réréseau de la santé, un peu coe
onon est en train de faire
l'l'Ontario en ce moment.
- - Discuter la semaine prochai,
lolors de la commission de la
sasanté, l'opposition, on verra
cocombien de temps, etc., mais e
vovous propose la question : si
vovous avez décidé que quelqu'un
ququi n'est pas vacciné, une
ininfirmière, préposé, médecin,e
popourra plus travailler près ds
papatients que ça va vous faire0
% % des personnels de moins,
pupuisse déjà à court de
pepersonnel.
- - Il y a deux choses que
j'j'aimerais vous dire.
PrPremièrement, il y a beaucoupe
pepersonnel qui vaccinait je l'i
didit, dans le réseau public ene
momoment, on parle de 90 %. Mais
ilil y a beaucoup de personnel
dadans le réseau privé, pas
seseulement au RPA, c'est-à-dire
leles résidences pour personnes
ââgées, il n'y a pas d'obligatin
vavaccinale, et on commence à
raravoir des cas qui remontent,n
n'n'est pas du tout dans des
scscénarios d'une première vagu,
mamais c'est notre devoir, c'est
nonotre responsabilité comme
gegestionnaire de dire : on ne
veveut pas que ça arrive une aue
fofois. Et là, maintenant qu'ona
dedes vaccins, on ne peut pas se
papasser de ça. Maintenant, les
memesures qu'on va discuter en
cocommission, écoutez, M. Roy, y
enen a plusieurs, on en a mis sr
lala table, on dit que c'est por
totout personnel de la santé qui
esest en contact de plus de 15
miminutes avec quelqu'un. On vet
auaussi regarder ce serait quoi
leles mesures, est-ce que c'est
papar exemple de mettre une
pepersonne sans solde jusqu'à tt
ququ'elle soit vaccinée? Je pene
ququ'il y a plusieurs choses qun
vava pouvoir faire, mais je peux
vovous dire : on a un objectif
trtrès clair, c'est de protéger
nonos gens qui sont vulnérables.
- - J'essaie de comprendre
l'l'urgence, parce qu'en même
tetemps, on dit que neuf persons
susur 10 ans déjà vaccinés, donc
c'c'est énorme, un taux de 90 ds
unune organisation, c'est énorm.
- - Je vous dis, M. Roy, que c't
leles gens qui sont dans le résu
pupublic, je suis en train de de
quque dans le réseau privé, j'ai
dedes gens qui ne sont pas
vavaccinés, j'ai des gens dans s
agagences de placement avec quin
fafait affaires qui ne sont pas
vavaccinées. Alors c'est pour ça
ququ'il faut avoir une logique
paparce qu'on ne peut pas avoirn
cecertaine façon de travailler
avavec les gens et une autre fan
nonos gens et laisser entrer le
vavariant. Regarder ce qu'on va
fafaire avec nos proches aidants
ququi viennent visiter les
papatients et c'est très comple,
mamais étant donné qu'on a
bebeaucoup d'expérience des tros
prpremières vagues, on va être
trtrès clair qu'il faut aller la
pupuis on va pouvoir le discute.
JeJe le répète, pourcentage plus
onon va aller chercher, c'est ds
gegens qui n'iront pas l'hôpita.
PoPour nous, c'est très importa.
- - Pour le passeport vaccinal,.
LeLegault avait dit qu'on ne vet
papas de commission parlementai,
onon juge qu'on a le droit de le
fafaire tout seul, et pour ça,
vovous voulez une commission
paparlementaire. Pourquoi?
- - Il y a une grosse différenc,
y y en a plusieurs, mais la
prprincipale, lorsqu'on parle du
papasseport vaccinal, c'est une
fafaçon de s'assurer que les ges
sosoient vaccinés et de pouvoir
papar exemple travailler dans...
dede permettre aux gens d'aller
dadans des services non
esessentiels, ce que ça veut die
dadans le fond, c'est une des
memesures sanitaires. Lorsqu'on
paparle de vaccination
obobligatoire, je l'ai dit, on a
totoucher l'intégrité de la
pepersonne, on dit qu'on vous
oboblige à vous vacciné, c'est e
grgrosse décision, puis le premr
miministre l'a dit cet après-mi,
onon est prêt à la recommander
acaccepter la recommandation de
l'l'santé publique, mais on veut
êêtre capable de discuter avec
leles syndicats, et c'est pour a
quque je fais une grande
didifférence entre une mesure
sasanitaire, mais en même temps
l'l'obligation qu'on vous on vet
coconférer aux employés de la
sasanté.
- - Et vous souhaitez que ce sot
enen vigueur pour la première de
dede ceux qui ne sont pas encore
vavaccinés dans le réseau privé,
papar exemple les RPA, visé le r
seseptembre pour la première doe
etet le 1er octobre pour la
dedeuxième dose.
- - Exactement. Dans le fond,
c'c'est être capable d'aller
chchercher nos dernières persone
ququi peut faire une différence,
paparce que dans certaines
cacatégories, on est déjà à 90 ,
9191 %, mais vous savez, le diae
esest dans les détails, on l'a u
dadans les RPA, dans les CHSLD,
c'c'est souvent un employé qui a
cacauser une contamination, on e
pepeut plus prendre des risquesà
mamaintenant.
- - Si vraiment les RPA que vous
avavez en tête.
- - On avait pas ces outils
l'l'avant. Maintenant qu'on a le
vavaccin, on veut être sensible.
- - On vient de voir les chiffr,
onon peut les revoir, les taux e
vavaccination dans la population
gégénéral, on est à 85 % au Quéc
prpremière dose de 74 %. Et vous
avavez dit 75 %, c'est votre
obobjectif fin août pour de dos.
EtEt vous dîtes non : la grande
gugueule on avance, mais
l'l'objectif avance en même tems
quque nous. Les plus 74.
- - Écoutez, vous le savez, M.
RoRoy, les conditions aux
écéchanges. Quand on a fait, ona
paparlé à l'santé publique au ms
dede mars que la première fois
ququ'on a dit qu'on voulait 75 %
dedes gens que l'on travaillait
avavec un variant, avec le
vavariants qui nous venaient du
UKUK. On a vu ce variants dans e
momonde, le variants est beaucop
plplus dangereux, beaucoup plus
cocontagieux, c'est beaucoup pls
mamal, il sera plus les jeunes,
leles conditions ont changé. Etr
ArArruda disait cet après-midi :
sisi j'écoutais son wish list,
cece qu'il aimerait, c'est d'avr
9595 %. Malek, c'est chaque
popourcentage plus me fait
plplaisir, parce qu'on est rendà
8585, puisé dans les prochaines
sesemaines, on est capable de
momonter à 86,87, 88, à chaque
fofois, c'est 75 000 personnes e
plplus vaccinés qui n'iront pasà
l'l'hôpital. Et c'est comme ça.
AlAlors oui, on a déjà des
cacatégories, Horatio a raison,n
a a des catégories de gens plus
ââgés qui sont déjà 90,92. Notre
dédéfi, parce que le variants et
trtrès forts chez les jeunes,
c'c'est d'amener les jeunes autr
dede vaccination.
- - Est-ce que vous êtes déjà
ororganisés la troisième dose?
- - oui, on a demandé une opinin
auau comité de nous revenir nous
didire que certaines catégoriese
pepersonnes les plus vulnérables
etet pour qui, un peu comme cela
s's'est fait en Europe, qui sert
unune bonne chose de faire une
trtroisième dose. Peut-être pas
popour la population en général
mamais pour certaines catégorie.
OnOn devrait obtenir une opinion
susur les prochaines semaine